GUY MY LIFE HE SMELLS LIKE
CIGARETTES AND RED WINE.
DON'T KNOW WHY.
ANYWAY WE BEGAN TONIGHT WITH
THIS GIANT SEAT VARYING MEMOS HE
GETS EVEN FIVE YEARS BELOW
NORTH ATLANTIC RIGHT WELL.
NEVER HEARD OF IT BEFORE BUT
THERE IT IS.
APPARENTLY JOE BIDEN CARE SO
DEEPLY ABOUT THESE MAJESTIC FEES
HE IS NOW PREPARED TO WRECK THE
MARITIME INDUSTRY FROM FLORIDA
TO MASSACHUSETTS IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE WHALES.
ELLIE IS A NEW REGULATION FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE AND IS DESIGNED
TO PREVENT VOTES FROM
ACCIDENTALLY HITTING
NORTH ATLANTIC RIGHT WHALES THAT
WILL RESTRICT THE SPEED OF ALL
BOATS OVER 35 FEET TO TEN KNOTS
OR THE EQUIVALENT OF 11 MILES
PER HOUR.
UP TO 11 MILES FROM THE COAST
KEEP IN MIND, THAT THERE HAS
ONLY BEEN FIVE DEADLY WILL
STRIKES BY BOTH IN THE PAST 15
YEARS.
FIVE THE TICKET, THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A CONFIRM WELL STRIKE, AND
EPHEDRA CHANNEL IF YOU WILL.
NOW IF THIS NEW REGULATION GOES
INTO EFFECT EXPERTS ARE WARNING
THAT POOR TRAFFIC WILL BE
CRIPPLED IN THE FISHING INDUSTRY
WILL BE DESTROYED.
HUMAN LIVES OF THE PUT IN DANGER
AND THEN YOU BOTH CANNOT OPERATE
SAFELY IN THE OPEN OCEAN AT TEN
KNOTS.
NOW OF COURSE BETWEEN THE BORDER
STRESSES AFGHANISTAN, AND THE
CRIME CRISIS AND NOW THIS EFFORT
TO PROTECT THE FEW WELLS WHILE
HUMAN LIFE ALWAYS SEEMS TO TAKE
A BACKSEAT IN THEIR BUYING
ADMINISTRATION.
OF COURSE THEY'RE WORSHIPING AT
THE ALTAR OF THE CLIMATE CALL,
AND THIS CASE SAVING WHALES THAT
ARE NOT EVEN REALLY BEING
KILLED, THAT TAKES PRIORITY.
JUST THIS WEEK BUT I AM PLEDGED
TO USE $8 BILLION, YOUR MONEY, A
BILLING WITH UPBEAT, SHUT DOWN
POWER PLANTS IN AFRICA.
THE CONTINENT BARELY HAS ENOUGH
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY
AS IT IS AND AS THINGS STAND
NOW, WHILE AFRICANS WILL SUFFER
IF THESE POWER PLANTS ARE SHUT
DOWN.
AND JOE BIDEN DOESN'T SEEM TO
CARE HE ONLY WANTS TO APPEASE
THE CLIMATE RELIGIOUS CULT AND
HE IS MORE THAN WILLING TO USE
YOUR HARD-WON TEST DOLLARS TO DO
IT.
IS A LOT OF MONEY THIS WEEK
DURING MEETINGS WITH WORLD
LEADERS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
JOE BIDEN HAD THIS TO SAY TO HIS
AFRICAN COUNTER BUT.
>> WE TAKE OUT WE CELEBRATE AN
AFRICAN DIASPORA THE
UNITED STATES.
MILLION STRONG, PULLING
AMERICANS IN THE UNITED STATES
TOGETHER IN A TIGHT EMBRACE OF
FAMILY.
>> AND WENT DOWN HERE FROM
THERE IF FOR THE ABOUT POOR
PEOPLE AND SEVERAL OTHER
PUZZLING MOMENTS TAKE A LOOK
>> IS ALSO SOME OF THE YEAR HE
VITAMIN C A COUNTRY I SAID BE
CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR
BECAUSE I MAY SHOW UP.
AND THE POOR RELATIVES ALWAYS
SHOW UP.
THE LESSON THAT ONCE ONCE NEVER
SHOW UP, THE POOR ONE STATE EAT
THEIR FOOD.
>> PROPS FOR AFRICA SOUNDS
LIKE SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
SAYING.
YOU KNOW -- THE DEAL ROOM.
KEPT ASKING WHERE IS THE DEAL
ROOM?
ALL THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
PLEASE FIND OUT THE VIDEO SO I
CAN IDENTIFY WHO YOU ARE.
THERE IS A MAN, AND I'M SURE YOU
ARE OUT THERE SOMEWHERE.
I SAID AT THE TOP OF THIS FORM,
ABOUT CLOSING DEALS AND WE
DELIVERED.
SO, JUST GIVE ME A FEW -- A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE DEAL ROOM.
FOR THE BENEFITS WITH
DELIVERANCE AFRICA.
-- THE DIASPORA OWNED SMALL
BUSINESSES, IS JOINTLY
ANNOUNCING $800 MILLION IN NEW
CONTRACTS.
>> : REMEMBER THIS IS THE SAME
ONE THAT IS NOT CRITICAL TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER BECAUSE HE IS
WAY TOO BUSY TELLS US HE HAS
MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO LIKE
SUING THE STATE OF ARIZONA FOR
ATTEMPTING TO SECURE ITS PORTION
OF THE BORDER WITH SHIPPING
CONTAINERS IN OTHER WORDS -- HE
HAD THE GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA
DURING JO'S JOB.
AND JOE IS NOT SHOWING BECAUSE
HE'S DOING HIS JOB IF THAT MAKES
ANY SENSE.
NOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THEY WANT THIS MAKESHIFT WALL
REMOVED IMMEDIATELY SO IT IS
EASIER FOR MORE EMIGRANTS TO
CROSS, AND THIS COMES BY THE WAY
WE ARE SIX DAYS AWAY FROM
TITLE 42 ENDING.
AND BY THE WAY THAT IS NEXT
WEEK, AND I WILL A NEW WAY OF
MASS MIGRATION -- AN IMMIGRATION
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
NOW THE STATE OF OUR BORDER HAS
NEVER BEEN WORSE, AND SECURITY
WAS LESS TERRORISM, GANGS, AND
SENTINEL, AND HERNE, AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, ALL THESE CRIMINALS
AND EVERYTHING IS GETTING WORSE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
BUT THAT IS APPARENTLY NEWS TO
JOHN PIER, BECAUSE TODAY
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
BRACED HER BOSS FOR WORKING HARD
WENT ON THE BORDER.
SI MALLORCA SAYING SAYING THAT
THE BORDER SECURITY TO LOOK.
>> : WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR
POLITICAL STANCE, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE POLITICAL STAGE
FROM THE REPUBLICANS OUT THERE,
AND THAT'S NOT HOW WERE GOING TO
FIX THIS ISSUE THEY WANT TO
DO -- THEY WANT TO SECURE THE
BORDER A LIVING DOING THAT WORK
ON OUR OWN.
AMERICAN SHOULD KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE THE WORK.
TO DEAL WITH WHAT WE ARE SEEING
AT THE PORTER SINCE DAY ONE,
WHAT AMERICAN SHOULD KNOW IS
THAT THEY PUT FORTH AN
IMMIGRATION REFORM POLICY, TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH A BROKEN SYSTEM.
>> : OKAY, YOU HAVE TO BE
KIDDING BECAUSE HOW CAN YOU SAY
THAT WITH A STRAIGHT FACE, HAVE
YOU NOT SEEING THE VIDEO AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, ARE YOU NOT AWARE
OF THE FACTS OR HE JUST FLAT OUT
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE YET
AGAIN?
JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO GET DOWN TO O
THE PORTERS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE,
IF HE IS OF COURSE MENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY CAPABLE THERE'S A LOT
MORE TO THIS COUNTRY BECOME
BEYOND WASHINGTON, D.C., AND THE
DELAWARE BEACH OF NANTUCKET
WHERE HE LIKES TO VACATION.
JOE BIDEN SHOULD CHECK IT OUT
SOMETIME BUT THAT IS LIKELY NOT
GONNA HAPPEN.
JOE BIDEN IS TO
LEAK HE'S TOO
LAZY AND FRANKLY